did you guys count the number of titans
and creatures seen in godzilla vs kong
the trailer
because we did and there are a few new
arrivals in the monster verse
we saw mechagodzilla which isn't really
a creature but a mechanized iron created
by humans
most probably from the remains of daegon
and ghidorah
then we see the much awaited nozuki or
warbats
in a battle with gong and finally there
were flying creatures that were seen
buzzing
around a gigantic kong in an underground
location filled with blue lighted
inverted monoliths
and a ground that seemed to look like
godzilla but shining with the same color
as the
nuclear powered dorsal plates and the
atomic breath so what are these flying
creatures here
well we have fun out and we will show
you in this
video right now so let's do this thing
so what did we see in the trailer we saw
kong fight against the nuzuki and
raising our battle legs
above his head it seems that he has
reached the mythical hollow earth
and the site where he was originally
from since there was a handprint of the
ancient kong imprinted on a rock
which is of the same size as gong's hand
and then we see kong standing up on top
of a shiny godzilla portrait slash
carpet or something
and he was surrounded by a flock of
these bad like creatures swooping down
and encircling him it seemed that they
are only an annoyance to the giant ape
and although they might be big
compared to titan's kong they seem like
insects
so what are they they look to be bad
like in design and fly around in a flock
like bats
but not as many these creatures are yet
to be seen anywhere in the most of us
movies or even comics
and it makes sense for legendary to
introduce new creatures into the
ever-expanding universe
especially with the introduction of the
hollow earth there would be a new
variety of creatures species and even
tyrants coming on to the foe
so there are various guesses and
theories out there
with a big section of fans claiming that
they are the psycho vultures of skull
island
which are sub-species of the leaf wings
seen in kong skull island of 2017
but these psycho vultures are bigger and
can shoot lightning from their mouths
unlike the leaf wings
another section of fans claim that they
are camazotz but clearly that wouldn't
be true since camazotz is a very large
titan
one that will appear in the upcoming
kong novel gvk kingdom kong
i'll tell you the description of this
titan camazotz is a massive cream
colored creature with demonic horns and
facial features
as well as large bat like wings covered
in long sharp spikes
he also has what appears to be a black
colored fur covering the entirety of his
torso
and parts of his neck his jaws are
filled with dozens of jagged dagger-like
teeth
so clearly they aren't camzos because
they are way smaller and do not share
the same traits
so with all the suspense we shall now
reveal what these creatures are
they are called hell hawks yes a
completely new creature that is seen in
recently leaked toy images
like we said in earlier videos toy
companies sometimes rename their toys to
make it easier for kids to remember
so the warbats were originally called
nuzuki
but they were kind of hard for smaller
kids to
remember and it could be the same thing
for these hellhogs but
it might be not as well only time will
tell anyway we will go with what we have
hellhawks are these nightmarish large
bat like flying creatures
that gorm will face inside the hollow
earth another one of his herculean tars
before retrieving the titan stormbreaker
let's get into the description of these
creatures by what we have seen in the
trailer and the toy images
let's combine both to get a wholesome
picture in the trailer we can see them
having some sort of a raptor like
beak a bird of prey like eagles and owls
then we see their very large wings which
seem to be very big compared to their
body
much like baths and draconian in design
with the four limbs evolved to become
wings and fingers stretched out as a
frame for the skin to attach between
them
their legs are very long with sharp
talons they don't seem to possess a tail
their colours seem to be dark creamish
brown in color and the most unique part
of their body are the dorsal plates that
look similar to godzilla that grow on
their back
the toy images seem to confirm the same
thing they have
bat like wings a sharp beak long legs
with talons and no tail
but since we cannot see the back of the
toy the dorsal plates are not visible
and if you think about it everything in
that place seems to reek of dorsal
plates
godzilla's shiny ground carpet thing
that kong is standing on
has this dorsal plate like things these
creatures and also maybe the balance
it would be a spine factory for all we
know anyway these creatures might live
there as guardians of the place of
feeding off the unique radiation that
exists
there and that's about it hellholes
that's what they are
tell us what you think put it down in
the comments section and do watch our
other trailer breakdown videos
like subscribe and hit that notification
bell for regular updates
till the next one take care fam